can we play a little game this is a
little work learn some workout game I'm
gonna call it get tough with huff so
what is the workout that everyone should
be doing must be doing I'm a huge fan of
dance cardio because it goes by really
quick everybody loves music and it's
it's fun you feel like you're actually
like you're not working out you know and
it kind of makes the time go by quick
and you're having fun and especially if
you take a class there's there's the
energy of other people and you're
laughing and you're enjoying each
other's company so even if you're a guy
and you don't believe in dancing you
should try to dance cardio it's really
fun what about an unhealthy habit that
everybody must strop who don't want to
see people doing it ooh fast food I
would say fast food I just feel like I
don't know I just I mean as guilty and
fun as it is to go through a drive-thru
best workout for your homes
um I mean what I really like to do
especially because you know we're all
busy and so sometimes you forget to do
something I always keep like wrist
weights with me and so if I just put
them on throughout the day I'll like
just be doing stuff and it's kind of
just toning without me even doing
anything
what about best workout for your abs how
do we get the famous julianne hough abs
I mean honestly dancing like dancing and
so great because there's all the little
details and all the little
and the little muscles that are working
without you even realizing but I mean
you can always do your your basic
crunches and stuff like that but I mean
I love a little bicycle what about for
your butt
but again ankle weights are great and
you can just you know you get on your
hands and your knees and you basically
do those like butt raises with your lips
your legs kicking back behind you or
squats are always great but again
dancing I'm telling you dancing is the
key when it comes to fitness and to
nutrition which are so important to you
you have a mantra like what are words
you live by oh my goodness I feel like
one of my mantras is that if I'm scared
to do something that means that I have
to do it but then also just being I keep
saying this about like a mental state
but the more that I am physically active
the more that my mind is clear and when
my mind is clear I feel like I can give
more of myself to those around me and
hopefully you know bring light and joy
and an infectious kind of energy to
inspire them to do whatever they want to
do so I think that's that's really a
kind of a key behind it all